the idea for this was actually my
husband Blair and Blair has been working
in the games industry for over 14 years
so he worked for Electronic Arts and
they primarily do console games so your
Xbox your Playstation and that and then
he worked for Zynga for a couple of
years and and they were the ones that
came out with farm bill so between those
two he really felt like the thing that
was missing was story and we've been as
I said we spent 20 months developing
this engine after a near-death
experience with him we decided to move
back to him till his hometown and he had
not lived there in 22 years and it was
just a chance for us to say you know
what we don't have any we don't have
kids who down the mortgage let's just do
this so we've managed to raise a quarter
of a million dollars Canadian to build
this with our local students in college
and so we're really excited we have some
really great people coming on board so
aside from the whole writing aspect of
it what would you advise to other people
that are looking to build a creative
startup I think it's fascinating i don't
know if it's different in canada than it
is the u.s. I know there's it's hard
everywhere is it it's okay great we've
got that out of way so you guys both
came to this decision that maybe it
sounds like maybe a lot of things were
stripped away or you had a lot of
epiphanies about what life really meant
to you yeah and then starting from
Ground Zero where you both were saying
let's do this what what were some of the
steps that maybe you could imagine I
think we first of all I've always felt
like the universe has guided us to this
point it's never let us run out of money
which has been a miracle and it really
was Blair had come up with this idea and
I thought okay we can only sign a six
month lease for this office because I
was scared and I think that's natural to
sort of put all of your eggs in that
basket what has worked really well for
us and it's very frustrating at first
because when you're trying to do
something we're trying to wedge
ourselves between the e-book and the
video game community so it's a space
that doesn't really exist it's hard
being pioneers some people that you meet
really get it right off the bat and then
other people they look at you
raised over eyes that's been challenging
and also it's challenging trying to
build this in a community that doesn't
have a lot of technology companies or
game company so we're an hour north of
Toronto so what my advice would be to
somebody who wants to take on a creative
startup is make sure that you're in a
community that supports you and find
mentors they don't have to be in your
community we're working with some
amazing mentors all around North America
it's exciting because we're now at that
stage where people can see it and it's
more tangible okay how do you identify
who your preferred mentor is I mean do
you see them online or maybe see an
interview and then say I'm going to send
them an email or a tweet kind of sort of
yeah so I use I use LinkedIn if people
are not using LinkedIn they really need
to be so I'll mean an article on maybe
like a venture capital firm that has
invested in a particular product that's
kind of sort of in our space so I'll go
and look and see who are those people
with respect to finding our mentors I
had reached out i did a an eight city
tour last year in 23 days i went to all
these different cities and I thought
okay I'm going to reach out to the
people at the top and see if I can't get
meetings because I'm a woman it was
really amazing to see other women
leaders say yes I'll take the time for
you so I met with the the head of the
International Game Developers
Association and she got to see her
prototype last year it's way better now
through that connection she was able to
connect me with other people in the
industry and that just kept going and
going and going and we eventually found
some people I mean I got to have a skype
call with one of the people that I've
admired for like 15 years and they have
made some of the games that my husband
and I love to play so it's amazing what
happens when you ask we've made some
very very daring asks the last year and
they're paying off its you don't get
what you don't ask for
you